are you sitting comfortably good cuz
it's about to begin
uncharted 4 is here and I'm very excited
a friend of mine check that out a little
bit he'd says it's amazing for those of
you who don't know this game was made by
Naughty Dog they made last of us the
title screen reminds me a lot of the
last of it actually it's very similar
I'm just really excited for a new let's
play on this channel it's been a while
since we started why don't we kick this
off we're leaving a like share this
video with your friends and family
because we're going on a new adventure
together baby
let's go as always we're gonna play on
hard cuz that's what we always do no
matter what my friend is German that's
my I did not this is his fault
god damn it Michael and here we go
no not quite yet
I am a man of fortune and I must seek my
fortune our yard I heard Henry Henry
Avery is 16 how exciting
I remember how amazing look
I really hope this will look good too
Arius
not good sexiest ever
that is not kid
hold on Oh
well [ __ ] accelerate oh I'm driving oh
my god what oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I
can't see Matt okay oh my god there's so
many boats what's a book do they do they
got smaller boats Ram those [ __ ]
their guns
what are we holding on to you I want to
ram someone I am accelerated holy [ __ ]
awesome [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
then you see what happened to your
friends dude Jesus what is his boat made
out of [ __ ] off [ __ ] say you're not a
mother [ __ ] where are we heading dude
dropping mine just keep heading for it
now okay okay try and dodge in mine
Jesus what a way to sit what the [ __ ]
come on Oh God big bug big bug my bad
man oh [ __ ] did I [ __ ] up or oh my god
this I sent you
well that was sexy you didn't like dude
Nate you're so nice
dad Oh what's up the propellers dude oh
that's more like my worst nightmare
propellers assent why would we go up for
air yeah well don't be a smartass oh my
god
I'm coming how are we still alive go
Nathan I don't worry about it what are
you talking about do you see how many
boats are
I have a [ __ ] that will be a yes that
will be a permit
show me your face babe there it is right
in the next baby
[ __ ] cool it's like I mean an action
movie man it's more common another one
fix the damn engine dude come on
Jesus show yourself thank you good
finally lime going dude I think I killed
someone
whoa that's a giant rug why don't we
turn off our lights so they can't find
us honestly this is like super am i
right how are we alive I don't know what
the [ __ ] was that that was so [ __ ]
cool Jesus right well we went back in
time just like that look at me you must
be tired of these lectures I know I'm
tired of giving them and now you have to
stay here with me weekend instead of
going on their treat with everyone else
I don't care I just want to find
treasures mom yes that is the crux of
the problem I mean none I don't see why
I'm the only one being punished because
you started the fight
you went getting back my book I told you
to leave those books in your room you
only have yourself to blame
doesn't give him the right did you
snatch it from me does that give you the
right to start throwing punches it
wasn't just about the book I love him
sorry
what was it then yeah what wasn't
nothing I'll get recognition the kid I
mean I know it's supposed to be Nate but
isn't an actor no matter what I try
you seem insistent on going down the
same sad road as your brother what a
waste
mean something going on outside and
we're gonna play as him as a kid Oh a
sickness Sam Sammy such a great name do
ya say that looks incredible look at
that I was I was praising him [ __ ] I
don't even remember that the game was
called the last game we played [ __ ]
hell look at this look at Austin ICU
this is why I prefer Playstation because
they have the best expenses man I'm
sorry I got it
it's place yeah let's get real I'm sorry
did it mean to start a console all right
this place like 10 times better all
right what do we do oh yeah cuz you can
climb like crazy and [ __ ] I keep
forgetting what game we're playing you
can't do this [ __ ] in other video games
it's like is there a box yeah well then
you're [ __ ] you can't pass okay so we
got to make it there yeah hey we got a
little friends coming with us so [ __ ]
cool the hype is real man the hype is
real feel so free while playing this
it's so [ __ ] liberating after playing
that [ __ ] monkey not this way
yeah good idea all right
he's gonna hear okay nice and quiet
alright we got a stop and [ __ ] now I am
100% playing this game from Sark's which
we finished by the way if you're
watching this right now get comfortable
because we're gonna be I care what do
you want me to do you know my opinion
I'm not ready to give up on him yet you
can't keep avoiding it I'll talk to him
in the morning Oh God
that was quite a terrible good night
father
good night sister Catherine good thing
father is blind Jesus Christ Oh
what an [ __ ] [ __ ] you none keep up on
me what are you gonna do a Morphin in
church where we go it this way something
here no it's me
same shirt my only shirt dude
I can roll it what it's my file there it
is I thought I pressed I have fighting a
busy language and I obtain items
father Ryan Diffie loss of privilege I
caught a glimpse of Edward wave okay
it's the thing that happened okay we
don't need to go into much detail all
right let's find our Sam Sam let's go
damn it
super agent Sam super hey Jen Sam that's
not my name though okay click No I love
it so good oh she's here yeah move it
goddamn you slow move that ass what'd
she do what she do she's gonna snort
some coke I knew it I knew it
[ __ ] we got to create a distraction or
sir
okay so hold what does that do like okay
when it's safe to roll out okay got it
look at those checkers this place that
was amazing and the best offer in the
universe
no way we're heading out of that window
I forgot my keys can you open the gate
for me coming father
we're going [ __ ] yeah that was awesome
drop you cray-cray I think I'm gonna die
really game oh dude you're crazy man I
would have [ __ ] died and then damn
son you crazy
see you Sam
oh just did it it just did it no
[ __ ] it's just dinner I don't
actually know where I'm going let's do
that are three things doesn't work
thanks for waiting Sam we're like your -
damn dick
I'm sorry I'll never try and make
another joke again that was just pure
awful I'm just going here because [ __ ]
it
almost there he said it I didn't okay
hurry hurry hurry hurry
ah [ __ ] there that's the insured way
isn't it come on go it I'm fine I'm fine
but someone's gonna have to fix that
let's scare him he hasn't found us yet
has he
scared you [ __ ] no oh he left this for
us okay I hope no one saw that oh it's
good to see you little brother
who's that I got a kiss oh really
again it's not [ __ ] it up with a nun
told me you'd stay out of trouble though
who's talking [ __ ] about us so I said
that dad dumped us here cuz we're
worthless and mom isn't he'll be Nathan
Nathan come on they're just saying it
because it gets you alright you just got
to learn to laugh it off you wouldn't
learn to laugh at I'm well do as I say
not as I do yeah
so what are you doing here like this
anyway
if the nuns catch you they're gonna call
the cops I got something for you and I
couldn't wait till Christmas what it's
outside
what happened Oh stay out of trouble
this is an exception mm-hmm
that is so amazing jump
nice jump dude look at this man I'm like
fascinated by everything look at this
thing it's so nice it's cool
some Bible retreat holy [ __ ] this is so
cool
whoa he did it right away but he's the
one decent guy in there you should come
and say hi dude Jesus dude will help
please this way this way
okay I'm coming oh god man
Lola oh I did it no problem I was bummed
dude yeah no that was super easy oh well
then you didn't prop it no because
tonight man I did I wish I thought I did
no it doesn't matter we're gonna take
the high road the high road just follow
me just watch yes well we take the high
road
have you done this before once or twice
once or twice
come on hey this game is something I
love it and love playing this game makes
me around and all the right for you
you know what I mean don't look at me
like that hey here we go
so what you been up to where I came
mostly you still dating that girl
Oh crystal on-again off-again current
wow dude awesome yeah it's reach crystal
nice she's a wonderful lady how dare you
know God's love it no glory
I hope laughs oh God
you got this dude that's [ __ ] far man
I hope they do after that it should pull
I know that was that was worth almost
name Jesse no big deal yeah nothing to
it
stay with me
I know it's a church but like we're
armed like I what does it call an ad
cool huh yeah behind you kids why am I
talking sorry
wait what did you say that night push
towards goal okay it's a jump coming up
okay
so now you're fine good heart yeah go oh
thanks for letting me check if it's
safer night [ __ ] you you're not even
gonna watch yeah that's right you better
watch cowabunga nailed it
what up ho whoa dude that was what
[ __ ] I'm not asking any more
questions that son of a [ __ ] blocking
[ __ ] oh oh no Nathan I'm sorry I jumped
into him
I meant to jump next to him actually I
wanted to see if I could lie on his back
and grab I thought that could be funny
if I did that back okay I won't [ __ ]
around anymore I will keep saying [ __ ]
around I can't jump that I just go
around the corner is that like a New
York accent
oh that does not look safe me no it's a
nice view huh yeah not bad it's [ __ ]
amazing move the lightning with textures
you ever been up here before this
particular roof but you do know where
you're going right dude what time is it
are you wait here
can you watch me you crazy son well your
[ __ ] oh I got a jump ok never go bros
can we do with this that's you gotta
time it right just don't over thank you
[ __ ] you chuck that do so fly whichever
way the wind is thanks Beth
really really I'll follow you leave what
why does he always do that Josh check in
my head box alright first try I'm not a
boy I'm a man hey now watch me nae nae
okay while reaching it's safe to Jim
okay Hey Dude how's it going man weird
that's cool though that's [ __ ] cool
man okay look at the Rope now you all
right there mate just hanging around
don't worry about it man what's he doing
oh okay waiting for me now what man
waiting for me again yeah
I'm in the way sorry you could could
have just told me that all right after
you
the ladder I need to keep you down or
something you pointed to the watch the
ladder right oh yeah you don't even have
to think wow just like that we're out
all right easy peasy check it out Judy
but you got the 250 250 what are you
talking about no this is the 500 CC twin
Oh where'd you lifted from whoa that's a
low blow
Oh changed man bought this with
hard-earned cash
Dixie what yeah what the only time you
pull a stunt like this is when you're
trying to make up for something you are
too smart for your own good you know
that all right I recognize him I got
this job pays well really well but
gotta leave town for a little bit what's
a little bit like a year at the most and
then I'll be back before you even know
it all right you're bailing on me come
on don't be so dramatic
it wasn't bad enough to leave me in that
place how could you do this to me Sam
right I'm doing this for you the money I
make is for the both of us and then a
couple of years when your rounds yours
take me with you
I can barely support myself I'll beat
Jim I know you think the orphanage sucks
you have no idea but it's the best thing
for you right now all right she's got it
trust me on that man it's not fair yeah
nothing about our lives has been fair
we've made it work thing
sure well you know the bike wasn't the
only surprise and I guess I'm gonna have
to ruin the next one what
I found mom's stuff everything that dad
sold I tracked down the buyer if just
name is just to make me feel better than
her sweet God we're on the other side of
town what do you say we go and get it
back you steal it it's not stealing if
it was ours to begin with I'm pretty
sure the cops aren't gonna see it that
way well that's not good
you ready for this so cute tell you all
right Bruce I'm gonna end the first
episode here so pumped to play more this
is so cool I really hope you bros
enjoyed this if you want to see more
please go ahead and leave a like leave a
comment and I'll see you bros tomorrow
with another episode as always stay
awesome rush squealed little Jack [ __ ]
you what the hell is going on here this
is crazy what oh god I did some bad in
there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh well then